[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'au 1er octobre les visiteurs sont
amenés à découvrir la 26ème édition de
sculpture en ligne l'exposition d'art
contemporain de Paris à Andrésy
accueille 10 artistes et 11 œuvres
celles-ci sont installés dans le parc de
l'Hôtel de Ville mais surtout sur l'île
de Nancy un lieu préservé où nous nous
sommes rendus en bateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le thème de cette année retour aux
sources les artistes ont alors imaginé
des œuvres avec des matériaux qu'ils ont
uniquement trouvé sur l'île Nancy comme
Sarah favrillo qui a fabriqué une
pirogue à partir des troncs d'arbres du
site où Jonas de lait qui a sculpté des
haut-parleurs en bois d'érable qui
miment le bruit de certains oiseaux le
message que souhaite faire passer
l'artiste crie d'alarme d'une
biodiversité en péril
et sur le parcours on croise également
la route d'une étrange cabane alors il y
a notamment l'oeuvre de Margo fontaine
dans laquelle nous sommes ici qui est un
château d'intention
donc cet artiste fait partie des de 21
travaux soit des lèvres soit des colles
soit de d'andrésiens ou d'autres
personnes qui ont voulu bien participer
à son œuvre
collaborative et les parties de peinture
végétale et de surtout de soins des
habitants ou des personnes qui ont voulu
voilà faire mettre en exergue leurs vœux
à la manière d'un château tibétain ou
les vœux s'envolent donc voilà chacun a
fait sa petite amie sa petite graine les
enfants ont parfois mis des notamment
sur la nature finalement c'est assez
interactif parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'oeuvres ou les personnes qui visitent
peuvent venir essayer il y a aussi
beaucoup de points de nature c'est
important aussi d'intégrer ce type
d'oeuvre dans sculpture en ligne c'est
aussi un virage qu'on a voulu cette
année par rapport un vrai moment
disruptif par rapport à aux autres
éditions d'avant là c'est vraiment
effectivement il y a beaucoup de
participatifs beaucoup de collaboratif
il y a eu beaucoup de bénévoles qui ont
utilisé
leur temps enfin qu'on donnait leur
temps pour participer aux œuvres avec
les artistes et effectivement il y a de
la collaboration au niveau des œuvres
elles-mêmes vous êtes aussi maîtresse
dans une école élémentaire les marottes
à Andrésy et du coup l'école a participé
à deux œuvres avec les enfants est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un mot on
s'est aperçu que les arbres ruisseaux
donc les arbres de quand on les achète
chez les pépinières et East ou des
choses comme ça été effectivement
emprisonnés pour qu'on les repère bien
pour éviter la tente etc et c'est vrai
qu'au bout de 15 20 ans c'est c'est
plastique était toujours en serré autour
de du tronc d'arbre donc les enfants ont
décidé d'enlever tous les plastiques on
les a on a utilisés pour les deux
productions de des maternelles pour le
radeau des marottes et aussi également
pour le filet de le pêcheur de filet
[Musique]
autre changement cette année sculpture
en Lille propose 11 points d'observation
sur la nature qui nous entoure poisson
cimes des arbres oiseaux insectes il
nous invite ainsi à prendre le temps de
vivre et à se ressourcer au contact de
la nature le thème de cette année est
respecté
[Musique]